you
welcome back everyone I hope you all had
a good lunch my name is Jason's hands
I'm from wired magazine i'm here with
dick Glover who actually has some
suspicions about I wouldn't it wouldn't
surprise me to learn that that dick was
a secret agent working for one of the US
as many foes hoping to undermine our
productivity he's the CEO of funny or
die which has has quickly become the
place to go for online video comedy he's
enlisted some of the biggest names in
humor to work with him its Will Ferrell
Zach Galifianakis rashida Jones pretty
much anybody you can think of every
month the site pulls down about 34
million views so I imagine a lot of that
comes from offices so it's not
surprising that the economy sucks anyway
Jake thanks for thanks for joining us
now I'd like to start by talking about
what the world was like when Funny or
Die launched in 2007 this was the era of
lonely girl 15 and user-generated
content it seemed that you know there
wasn't a place for Hollywood necessarily
in this new streaming media world and
yet you guys found this intersection
between Silicon Valley and Hollywood and
sort of doubled down on a list
production talk to me about that
decision I will but in a minute the the
a threw us a curveball one of the things
they asked when when when they
graciously invited me here was could we
premiere a video here and I said with
production schedule couldn't guarantee
it and and so we do have a video that's
actually 24 hours old it's not a clear
premiere that we wanted to show to get
everybody back from lunch and hopefully
get you far away from sean parker and
jimmy fallon which is impossible to
follow but this is for those of you who
know Matt Morrison who's the star of the
TV show Glee we were
to find out a little bit about how he
became Matt Morris we can roll that
video where did I learn from Matt
Morrison Matt taught me a lot about
surfing you know and really how to ride
that wave out to the very end you know
and in turn that told me about love and
life and how to cook an oatmeal frittata
and how to build up my pics and so I can
see all six of my abs now no I've never
actually met in that I mean but he did
teach me about the goonies and those
great Haiti movies flooded a navigator
you see I wanted to be a show business
for as long as I could remember so the
ripe old age of 18 I packed up all my
belongings I set out of my my
grandpappy's busted up jalopy and headed
for Tinseltown Californa somebody
could make me beat you finally got
something I dishes but never landed them
I guess my nice guy personality never
struck the right chord I will be reading
for the role of Zed hope fiction the
is sleeping oh wait the gimbap
episode what's in the box OH could you
put your mouth on the curb please I just
couldn't catch a break but I wouldn't
give up before the map was on Glee I
worked with him on a courtroom musical
drama called plea it was a it was pretty
crap the jury I have one thing to say
this man ha i said this man
every time he sings his clients die ah
and you're gonna fry look at you plea
was cancelled halfway through the first
episode it was an industry record I lost
the case on purpose you know
I promise you pleats out there a DVD
boxset is on its way
the show had some problems they often
broke out into song but nobody ever
broke out of jail flea was cancelled
halfway through the first season but I
promise you freaks out there a DVD box
set it on its way
I also promised the rest of the videos
will just be clipped very short we
wanted to watch a whole one no that was
fit was fantastic it was great so what
were so as I was saying this sort of
thing is not the kind of thing you would
have foreseen back when you guys started
again it was user-generated content was
what was happening so yeah that point I
think most people remember everybody Oh
user-generated content is the future of
the web the future of content everybody
is a publisher and now with YouTube
everybody can be a video publisher and
and and people were literally building
companies to try and exploit that that
situation and the son of a Sequoia
Capital partner was an aspiring stand-up
comic and and it actually is now a
professional stand-up comic and he said
the dinner table literally you know hey
Dad you know I go on YouTube there is so
much crap how do I find the good stuff
why doesn't somebody do a hot or not of
comedy videos and remember hot or not
was a site where you posted a picture
people could vote hot or not and he said
wow that's a great idea i'm going to be
down in LA i'm meeting with CAA a talent
agency and that's a great idea actually
and we'll do it and the next thing you
know they put together a deal where will
Ferrell and his partners our equity
partners in the company and and that was
the belief and I think we have a clip of
by serendipity the first video they ever
did as I believe it's still the most
viewed video ever on the internet and we
have a quick clip of what started it
you need to relax it'll call me
I'm a grown man fun of me cry I'm not
doing so good gonna pay you I'm working
three jobs right now Morgan nights I'm
driving I'm driving a cab I'm inside
with my buddy right now just going over
my resume okay you know what you need to
relax look what do you need your money
so fast come on you scare me you're an
alcoholic but so what happened literally
when that video hit there were no
employees of the company there was a
website that had been produced by a
fella who was running another sequoia
company and had some excess servers and
they literally started watching you know
I think it got up to about 30,000 views
an hour fairly quickly from no marketing
know anything and they immediately found
two guys who were sitting in the Sequoia
incubator they just sold a company and
they said your employee one your
employee to go start building something
fast and they ended up building a
terrific video serving platform and kind
of social media interface if you will
with it there was not that sophisticated
back then but it but existed and so
everybody felt wow we've invented the
model which is take user-generated
content with a mechanism for editing it
Mary it up with
sessional content and celebrity on a
fantastic platform that serves videos
faster than YouTube we're going to go do
20 of these and went out and did deals
in action sports with Tony Hawk culinary
with Tom Colicchio one of the top chefs
a thing called it was a like American
heroes kind of thing a video gaming one
and all of that and then
september-october of 07 happened 07 08
08 08 happened where the markets crashed
everything else and that's about when I
had come in we're not very good at audio
there but anyway um and we said hey we
better figure out and focus on what
we're really good on and you know what
the platform it's great and to this day
we have or we've never crashed no matter
how viral one of our videos goes videos
load really really quickly but that's
just a price of entry that's not a
competitive advantage nobody watches a
video because it loaded faster they sure
will not watch if it doesn't load fast
but so that's not really it our other
partners were not for whatever reason
that's quite the same level of
involvement as what I refer to as team
Farrell was and continues to be and so
we said let's get focus on comedy
necessity being the mother invention
that's we do strip everything else out
of the company focused on that focused
on the social media angle around it and
how to use that and not come would have
had you know that kind of growth since
right so is there some sound tweaking we
can do great thank you guys it's like
Robert Goulet over here so and in the
intervening years you know we've now
seen the premium content is the name of
the game you know YouTube has gone from
only girl 15 to scrambling around trying
to sign up as much premium content they
can and Netflix as well and they're
paying top dollar for these things and
and you guys produce your own premium
content very cheaply which
which surprises me so talk about your
business model you're not totally
ad-based you're not subscriptions how do
you guys make money well the model is is
really fairly simple keep the cost of
content low keep the cost of marketing
low and and distribute widely and
everywhere for through whatever medium
it it it's appropriate for for any of
the content now that's much easier said
than done obviously and that the way we
keep the cost of content down is we have
a lot of emerging talent who works both
in the company and outside and by
definition if you're in your first job
with less of a resume behind you you are
less expensive than Ron Howard or
someone who people have worked with us
who were obviously far far more
successful and far far more expensive
second just watch costs and overhead and
you know if they come then we will build
it don't get out and ahead of yourself
the second is we control all aspects of
the business it's a three-legged stool
we have the content leg which is
primarily out of LA where we produce
almost all of the video we have the
sales leg which is based primarily in
New York but with offices in San
Francisco Chicago in LA and again where
we control it from start to finish we do
all our ad ops and everything else which
is part of the third leg which is Palo
Alto where we have all the engineering
technology platform operations and also
all the social media and in every case
it's where the world class athletes are
can you find great social media people
in Austin Texas yes you can are there
more of them in Palo Alto are they on
the cutting edge more amount of chances
are the answers yes same thing on
content in LA sales in New York and then
once we go out we have a piece of gundam
we have the website
that if you do the math if you keep the
cost of content down and for our average
videos not a big hit video cost maybe
twenty five hundred dollars to do 30 to
35 of those a month if they do an
average video for us we do about 40,000
views you know there'll be about 7 ad
impressions per view that's you know
about 280,000 if you have an effective
CPM of ten dollars and knock on wood
ours is higher then that video is
profitable and and you repeat that month
you have more profits then if you do the
math on a hip video if we know we've got
a name talent and we can talk in a
minute about why all this a-list talent
wants to work with us and we put a
little more money say we produce it for
five thousand dollars and that it does
700,000 views and by the way we've had
you know well over a hundred of them
have done over a million views some as
many as 80 million views a number in the
teens and millions of views but she was
seven hundred thousand you know that
again at seven impressions per view that
will work out to about five million
impressions and you have then made 10x
of this ten-dollar CPM you will have
made 10x return on that video then we
have incubated product we've created a
library we have now things which have
come from the website in some way shape
or form either through the talent to
being an actual video whatever we have
television shows we going to go into our
third season a production with HBO with
a show called Funny or Die presents for
which we get licensing fees and
production fees that we have a show that
we're about to close a deal on for 12
episodes of sort of a man on the street
gain kind of show that's very very funny
it came from a talent that was in the
website we just last week premiered a
show on Comedy Central called John
Benjamin
van again the same model and we have two
pilots that are currently being reviewed
a couple of other networks so let me
just jump in here I mean if key to this
whole to making this business plan work
is low cost of producing content it's
it's how do you get you know obviously a
lot of people tuned in to see Will
Ferrell right a lot of people tuned in
to see jewel or jack black or whoever it
is you know usually those guys are going
to like I can't go out and get Jack
Black to do a 30 second video for me so
how what what are you guys offering sure
that gets these guys to do this for
cheaper for free why don't we you saw
him at morrison why don't we run next
thing which is a series of just short
clips of a bunch of a-list celebrities
and then i'll tell you why each one of
them did it because there are examples
of a model of why these people will work
for free
hi my name is Lindsay and I'm searching
for love I'm a workaholic a shopaholic
and according to the state of California
and alcoholic as well as a threat to all
security guards the perfect mate loves
long walks on the beach car chases on
the PCH antiquing and passing out in
Cadillac Escalades hello I'm Joe machine
and this is Charlie Sheen's winning
recipes winning steak is done he's got a
spatula it's a cooking one for a warlock
tastes like winning warning I'm actor
james Van Der Beek the odds are good you
know me best five-second clip of me
crying yep that's me on Dawson's Creek
so I started a website where you can
find short clips and be a voting dozens
of other feelings james Van Der names
calm as mild sadness super sad saw a
10-year anniversary crying addition the
sheer panic many many more for you don't
want to be with someone like me I'm
difficult
come on wrap up with your eyes hungry
d we'll start with the last one work
back Helen Mirren and Billy Crystal
doing a vampire take off why in the
world would they do that well because
they could they could do whatever they
wanted with us and for someone like
Billy Crystal like Damon you know Helen
Mirren to be able to literally go and
shoot and that was the biggest shoot we
ever did actually in a couple of days
and no interference from us what do you
want to do whatever you want to do do it
will help in any way shape or form and
in that case we did an awful lot of help
on the production but it was written by
two sons and laws Utley crystal actually
and it was directed by one of his
daughters but he could do whatever he
wanted and in Hollywood where they're
used to tremendous interference creative
freedom to do what you want is like you
know almost a drug to them the second
part of it is is risk free if that thing
nobody saw it in a bombed nobody's going
to say Billy Crystal is any less
valuable as an actor or Helen Mirren
that that it has no downside has a huge
upside in fact you know the amount of
publicity that it got was was right
around post Oscars and everybody wants
billy crystal back analysis the third
reason that they did it was Helen Mirren
had a movie coming out the next week and
it's a promotional vehicle people were
talking about her especially the young
demographic that we appeal to that's
very hard to reach and so for her the
motivation was the same reason she'll go
on Jay Leno or the Today Show it is to
be out in front of this audience when
you've got a
another project back james Van Der Beek
big star teen idol television shows
wanted to do a comedy and literally
couldn't get even consider for comedic
roles if agent manager came to us said
but we work with him and come up with
some videos and our team wrote it
produced it did it all with him end of
story this fall he's starring in ABC
comedy that he you know was able to
prove that he did have the comedic
jopson wasn't just a heartthrob he's
found her back huh very exciting you
know and then Lindsay Lohan and Charlie
Sheen both very much in the public on
for you could argue all the wrong
reasons they wanted to show hey we get
it we have a sense of humor about it
this will help us get through this this
will keep us from looking being looked
at just as you know bad people or
whatever so from their perspective is
very much an image and a PR thing and a
lot of the things and the only one we
didn't show an example of is people will
have causes that a charity something
else and it's a way to get attention and
we're happy to say you know please give
to you know this charity whatever it
might be that it's the message now the
element of your business model that we
didn't talk about yet is the branded
entertainment that you guys do so I
believe we have maybe we should start
with the the sample of that we can give
a clip for you know those you not
familiar the people in it LL Cool J
Snoop Dogg a guy named Zach lady who's
in a television show called Chuck and
less than perfect and then a guest star
at the very end and again this is a
short clip from a much longer video
Oh
mmm
halo reach can't reach me baby you can't
reach me dog
triple kill okay this hail me now that's
a Wayne Newton plays halo
and what was in the video ll cool j &
snoop dogg were trying to distract each
other they had marching bands come by
they had pizza people they had scantily
clad people they exactly be trying to do
it and and all of it and the model there
is clearly was an ad for Halo Reach
that's what it was but it was done as a
very funny video and again all the
people that say this young demographic
oh they don't like advertising they
won't tolerate it whatever couldn't be
farther from the truth they don't like
bad advertising they don't like
advertising that doesn't talk to them so
a lot of companies now will come to us
and say let's create a funny piece of
content not an ad not you know let's
just sell a message but what's a funny
piece of content that somehow will get a
message through to this audience that
hey we're cool and then you know the
part of it we haven't talked a lot about
that plays into it that's where our
social media is important we use social
media not as a marketing tool but
there's another way to just be a part of
our audiences lives and to have them be
a part of our lives it's just another
place for us to get the voice of the
brand out there so you know I think
we're the number 15 brand on Twitter
we've got two and a quarter million
followers we've got what it is now two
point nine million Facebook Likes
between wills page and arson you know a
bunch of things that we do with facebook
connect but all of its done to just keep
in touch with this group and not just to
say watch a video or come to a website
or watch TV show but rather just what's
happening in your life here's what's
happening in ours and we'll take like a
halo reach and we'll talk about it in a
way that is relevant to them and fun as
opposed to oh there's a new video game
you should go buy it all right well I
think that pretty much it's all the time
we have so things thanks very much dick
I really appreciate it
you